Chuck this is an intractable problem it
seems for the President Vladimir Putin
can talk all he wants but seems to have
impunity in his actions well that's
right and I think some of the
president's critics will say this is
this is what you get for not checking
him soon for not being tough on him
sooner for trying to for trying to bring
him in when you when you needed Russia
to do the Iran deal but then you ended
up empowering him a little bit he feels
as if hey I was there for you in Iran
I'm going to assert myself here in Syria
and it's also a reminder of just what a
failure the Syria policy has been the
president's you know has basically never
been able to figure out Syria uh and it
yes it's an intractable problem but it
is been paralysis you know there really
hasn't been there has been such a fear
of getting drawn into a quagmire that
that has become a quagmire and so I
think at this point it basically Putin
has forced the United States to have to
to have to consult with with with rush
on this and essentially change its
policy on a side whether they like it or
not they going to cook they're trying to
claim they're not going to do this but
they have no choice or we could get into
an accidental military confrontation
with Russia and then I say accidental
because if you know they're bombing
people were training on the ground um
yeah out of that out of that it yeah
those kind of questions are why i was
asking the other day why anyone would
want to run for president well while all
this is going on at the other end of
capitol hill maybe things are beginning
to sort themselves out after john
boehner 'he's resignation what can you
tell us about what the leadership is
beginning in the next leadership is
beginning to look like well look i think
we know who the speaker is going to be
Kevin McCarthy but boy he said a
horrible week in his and getting his
campaign off the ground I mean I think
he's really he really blew it on his
comments about the Benghazi committee
when he talked about him in political
terms and essentially said hey isn't it
great what we've been able to do to
Hillary Clinton
Benghazi committee which of course the
Clinton campaign was able to use like a
cudgel and more importantly a whole
bunch of Republicans have criticized
McCarthy for his words on this because I
think mccarthy is misread some of the
Republican base many in the Republican
base take the Benghazi committee
seriously and they've always feared that
the leadership always viewed it is just
a a way to calm the troops you threw him
a bone and if you recall the leadership
never wanted a Benghazi committee and
then they slipped as a way to get
conservatives on board when they reopen
the government the last time so i look i
think mccarthy is still going to be
speaker but you know he's not going to
get off the moon anymore and he starts
in a weaker position than he ever
planned I don't know why anybody would
want to run for president but I can see
why you'd want to be host of meet the
press because there's always idea I
don't know why everyone you got eager
out you cut the best job in Washington
very quickly who's on the show this
weekend well I got Donald Trump I'm
gonna do a sit down with him face to
face in his office this weekend i also
have Cecile Richards had a Planned
Parenthood and of course we're going to
deal with Syrian Russia with two men two
former players from the Obama and Bush
administration we will be listening to
Chuck Todd a host of NBC's Meet the
Press you can see it on NBC sunday
mornings and then listen to it here on
Bloomberg radio at eleven o'clock and
three o'clock